[Music]
foreign
it appears we are almost ready to depart
pity we didn't have a bit more time to
spend on spell casting I presume you've
been practicing the Spells we worked I
have professor
I'd never seen anyone take so quickly to
a secondhand wand you'll be a force to
be reckoned with when you get your own
thank you Professor fig I appreciate you
working with me
foreign
cryptic description of our location did
not thought you're finding us I've
operated to more vaguely to find
destinations than this though I confess
I may have miscalculated slightly on my
first try gave quite the Fright to some
fear to go is in the West End
it's been much too long when I received
Doral I must say I best not speak here
Elias are
of course why don't we speak on route to
Hogwarts we have a start of term feast
and a sorting ceremony to get to
wonderful idea as long as your young
child here doesn't mind me tagging along
not at all sir after you
ages since I've been to the castle
would be good to see the old pile of
rocks
[Music]
foreign
just barely
and who is your traveling companion
a new student
new one yes sir I'm starting school as a
fifth year
how extraordinary it is indeed none of
the faculty has ever heard of anyone
being admitted to Hogwarts so late nor
have I of course as the other fifth
years will have been honing their
magical skills for four years now the
Headmaster asked if I could get her new
student up to speed a bit before the
term begins
well you couldn't have asked for a
better Mentor Professor fig is not only
an exceptional teacher he's also a
remarkably intuitive and gifted wizard
Mr ozric is prone to flattery I dare say
it's one of the reasons he's risen so
far at the ministry
have you seen this
I have opinions differ as to how great a
threat Round Rock really is
although I've yet to convince my
colleagues that the ministry I believe
he is a significant threat and it was
your wife eliazar who alerted me to his
activities months ago Miriam
how
she wrote to me about ran Rock before
she died
wondering what the ministry knew about
his activities
before I could respond I
received this
it was the last thing she sent me
earlier it came to me via her owl
but with no correspondence I can only
assume that she had to get rid of it
quickly
to keep it safe presumably from ran Rock
I cannot open it whatever magic protects
this is powerful indeed it looks like
Goblin metal
is that glow
nor do I
Merlin's beard how did you wait
we did
[Music]
yeah yeah
the key
are you all right
you're hurt
perhaps a bit
it's wicked World potion that's stuff
will write you in a second
what happened
poor George
I can't believe he
what the hell got into that damn thing
attacking a carriage mid-air
a typical Dragon would never
fessa
sir
where are we
I'm not sure
but that key you discovered was clearly
a Porky Porky
an item Enchanted to bring whoever
touches it to a specific place
I'm feeling better sir if you'd like to
look around a bit
I would
stay close
we've no idea who created this Porky
or why
foreign
key take us farther from London than the
carriage traveled
somewhere in the Scottish Highlands so
those ruins
if the porky was meant to lead us there
I do this has not been the day either of
us expected but Miriam sent that Porky
to George for a reason
and I believe that she and now George
died in pursuit of whatever it was meant
to lead to
if you're sure you're all right and
wouldn't mind indulging me I'd like to
have a look around absolutely sir good
let's see if we can find a path however
faded it may be
mind your step
[Music]
where do you suppose your wife got the
poor kid
a good question
Miriam spent years searching for
evidence of a long forgotten form of
ancient Magic
ancient magic yes a powerful magic
wielded by a rare Feud that seems to
have been lost to time
Hogwarts Castle was built by and is
itself a stronghold of that ancient
Magic
I don't know where she came into
possession of the book key
but I am certain it was to do with that
search ah there's the path down below
this way
but sir why was your wife searching for
evidence of Lost Magic Miriam wanted to
understand why such powerful magic
disappeared from The Wizarding World
spoke of the good it could do but magic
is no different than any power
what really matters is the one who
wields it
eyes it's not cold enough here
it appears to be a sort of enchantment
someone wanted to block this path
let's see some of that one work you were
practicing
focus on the center
excellent
foreign
that was a bit rougher than I'd expected
ah up there
oh
we're close now it's just ahead
get to yourself
thank you
almost there
[Music]
why would someone have built this here I
suspect they valued their privacy
that Porky led us here for a reason
let's have a look around for anything
that seems
out of place
[Music]
Professor it's a mural of some kind
perhaps our host was a noted seer
interesting
Professor this statue this may have been
his home
[Music]
that Enchanted crystallized Stone again
but what could it be blocking
what's this
Professor fig
how odd why would someone have conjured
that Enchanted Stone here and how is
there a room behind it
what room
I don't see anything there's that glow
again like the glow on the porky
container
foreign
's name
Rick's heart
where are we
I don't believe it
hello
[Music]
it can't be
uh just a moment
[Music]
welcome to Gringotts Wizarding Bank
Vault number 12 I presume
[Music]
the White's Pokey oh yes of course
this way then
stay close
[Music]
after you
and keep your hands inside the cars if
you don't wish to lose them
[Music]
how many votes are there
hundreds in fact you'll see quite a few
on our way to vote number 12 as we speak
we're just beneath the main lobby the
vultures
are private entrances to the bank common
at Gringotts they are most and common
only one with great wealth or power all
both could have arranged for such a
service
you want to take a breath
a what
that waterfall washes away all
enchantments it's a security measure
experience the thief's downfall before
have you heard of it the SE are the low
results that we're passing now how deep
are we going Vault number 12 was
commissioned shortly after Green Cross
was founded over four centuries ago he
resides in the deepest part of the bank
settling with quite a distance to go
Vault number
vote 12. if momentous day
[Music]
on your way
thank you
Professor the armband that God was
wearing was glowing like the glue you
saw on the porky container but darker I
saw that same glow dragon's collar yeah
what was that we were just wondering
about that Goblin back there did he
watches over the oldest section of the
bank
rare anyone goes there anymore
here we are
[Music]
when was the last time this Vault was
accessed a goblin has been stationed at
my desk for hundreds of years
in that time no one has visited Vault
12. until today
12. thank you for your help
what do you suppose we should be looking
for I'm not sure so I wonder if you mind
instructions for Vault 12 indicate that
I am to Grant access to the holder of
the key and then close the door
push it back
Professor that was certainly unexpected
let me think
there must be something here
revelia perhaps
revelio
yes a revealing charm no time like the
present let's see what we're missing
shall we
ready your wand and focus
[Music]
foreign
there I saw something
move a bit closer and try again
[Music]
a door
well that's a start
there's that symbol again
I don't suppose you see a weight too I
do Professor that's
the same glow as the one I saw on the
porky container
and I dare say we are about to discover
the secret of this Vault lead the way
lumos
this is no ordinary Vault I suspect we
will need to earn our way out of here
what do you mean earn our way out
think this is some sort of test I do but
to what end I can't say stay close there
will be no disapparating if things go
poorly not out of Gringotts
[Music]
I see something up ahead what is it
that glow again but on the floor
[Music]
what happened
when I moved towards the globe it
suddenly seemed as if the ground was
swirling about
are you all right
yes sir I'm fine
you seem to have caused the floor to
change
that statue
what statue
I see some sort of statue but only as a
reflection in the floor
revelio I presume this is what you saw
reflected in the floor
it is the reflection's still there but
the statue's positions don't match
wait when you moved the reflection
turned in the direction of the light
perhaps you should cast lumos
lumos well done
now the reflection is turning towards me
it does follow the light
explosives
the fingers
stay close
[Music]
lumos
where am I supposed to go
what's happening
the Wisps of magic seem to be leading me
somewhere
Ah that's where they're leading me I
glow again
Rebellion I suppose I'm on my own this
time
lumos
I need to align these statues with their
reflections
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
there you are
how did you
what is this place I don't know
but I found this floating above that
basin
that is no mere basin
that is offensive
for viewing memories
I wonder
foreign
[Music]
borders in place
the party is well hidden perhaps too
well
I wonder if the path we've created may
be impossible to follow
it will only be impossible for one who
cannot see traces of ancient magic as I
can your ability to see what others
cannot will not be enough Percival
we are entrusting the one who embarks on
this path with Powerful Secrets with
knowledge others will do anything to
obtain yes and if we are correct Charles
the ritual wizard who completes the
trials will have proven themselves
worthy of that knowledge
and the responsibility that accompanies
it
we've done all that we can
[Music]
that's what you're seeing
the glow that surrounded them yes sir
astonishing can I see Magic
traces of an ancient magic to be precise
the magic that Miriam had always
believed existed
could never
[Music]
Miriam and perhaps George
died in pursuit of knowledge that has
been dormant for centuries
and you it seems
are the key to understanding why
we were different than it did a moment
ago
someone's coming
who were they I don't know but sir you
shouldn't be in
[Music]
I was right
ran Rock
seems my reputation precedes me
I was beginning to think no one was ever
going to visit dragons walks and why are
you here
no need for that just give me whatever
it is you found here and we collect
bygones be bygones
sir
they had the key to the vault
choose your next words wisely I I only
meant that the instructions to Vault 12
were quite clear
sir I must insist I was to Grant access
only to one with the key
I have no patience for traitors
no
where were we I
giving you anything
hmm well
perhaps your young friend here will be
more healthy
[Music]
foreign
are you all right
fine sir
I've never seen so powerful a goblin
he seemed
holy unaffected by my magic
where are we
[Music]
it can't be
it seems those who set up the pensive
the locket and the path to both wanted
someone with your ability
to end up here
come
we have a sorting ceremony to get to
[Music]
foreign